If you about what's going on, I will literally just take all
the screenshots of all the messages that I have between you,
me, and Brett. I'll remove you guys' personal identifying information
and I'll release it on Twitter. It is not a crazy stance to say
that engaging in this kind of reckless behavior while under civil
lawsuit for other reckless behavior is patently
insane. And I will not be gaslit by moral cowards into other
perspectives.
Okay. So, what happened is Connor and Destiny had their crash
show. Connor said you're playing with the grouper's wife and
they had this whole fight and all this, right? Connor, you come
to find out that the guy, the devil guy, the thing he told Connor
was that this woman, his his wife, his ex-wife, whatever, was
doing some sort of age play where they she involved the right?
They were step parents like doing something to the
And Connor asked the wife about it and the wife said, "No, the
husband's just husband's just making it up cuz he like wants
to win in a breakup or he's mad and all of this and he's making
it up." So, Connor went on his merry way with like told Destiny,
"You shouldn't engage with these kinds of people anymore. They
obviously have some problems and it's really bad, right?" It
seems like the allegation has come out that now Destiny got pictures
of this guy's, too, which is crazy back in I I assume November
before. Come to like this month, Connor realizes that Destiny
is still texting this woman, the woman who he thought was just
doing age play with him, some sort of babysitter, right? And
then Connor finds out that this woman wrote into Mr. Girl
and discussed like explicitly not not just age play, not just
babysitter stuff, but fantasizing about being the step parents
of each other's and involving the in the role play, okay?
And that changed Connor's mind basically immediately once he
found out that that was the allegation, that the allegation was
true, and that Destiny had continued to engage with this woman
after Connor had called him out for it. And so, that's like the
quick rundown of why Connor was so upset, why he felt the need
go public with a bunch of this
you find out that uh your friend
who is being sued for a substantial amount of money, who's lost
$800,000 in his lawsuit
is doing age play with a BPD Discord girl and you tell him that
he's a and he's ruining his life. >> I like it's unfortunate
that Connor picked this up from Destiny's community. I just like
it is stigmatization that doesn't need to be done.
>> And then
I find out on Friday, Saturday, I think
that he is still
the BPD E-girl
uh within the past 72 hours
I have found evidence that they did more than babysitter role
play
and you think I'm the one who needs to chill the [__]
out?
How about you go tell your internet dad to stop
>> Oh boy, oh boy.
>> Hold on. Uh within the past 72 hours
I have found evidence
that they did more than babysitter role play
and you think I'm the one who needs to chill the [__]
out?
How about you go tell your internet dad to stop role playing
How about that [__]
>> Oh Jesus Christ.
What the
What has CONNOR WHAT HAS CONNOR GOT? WHAT HAS CONNOR GOT? Oh
my god. >> Don't don't tell me it's normal. Don't tell
me off the scenarios is normal. Don't tell me that [__]
It's not normal. It's freak [__] Steven's
destroying himself.
And I'm not interested in being a part of his self-destruction.
So, if it wasn't the merits, it's the
>> Well, you could say that, but like you said it in public,
and that's wrong.
Well, the prob- the problem there is it sounds like he said it
in private, and the private criticism just didn't take. Private
criticism was not considered
or cared about.
That's what it sounds like to me.
>> doing this because of you. I'm doing this in spite of
you. Steven and I hung out several times throughout 2025.
Then, in November of 2025,
I was contacted by a man on Twitter. This gentleman says, "I
am a traditional Catholic. I am married. My wife has destroyed
our family for Destiny, and no one's doing anything about it."
So, I go, "Huh? Well, I do like Steven, but I'm not the kind
of guy who ignores a problem. So, let me go ahead and check this
out." And I talked to this gentleman, whose current profile on
Discord is called And Devil says, "My wife and I are military
veterans, and she has been in a communication relationship with
Destiny since February of 2025."
And the reason why this is important to is because
>> it's very likely like some kind of stress-induced thing,
right after the >> Steven made the argument, as silly as
it that he had substantially reduced his gooning, and that he
was not engaging in reckless sexual behavior the way that he
Now, what the husband further said is that they engaged in step-parent
role that they sent pictures of the family, spec- specific details
unknown, that he was deeply, deeply, deeply upset by this, that
he wanted vengeance against Steven, and while the specifics may
be unclear in these series of messages as to whether or not he
wanted to commit suicide against Steven, he's welcome to release
the logs and show whether >> Dude, the Vyvanse didn't work.
The Vyvanse was supposed to fix all this. THE VYVANSE DIDN'T
WORK. >> EVER expressed a homicidal desire for I have logs
of the wife saying that her husband told her repeatedly that
he desired that Steven worked
>> So, when Destiny heard that Connor was going to release
this, by the way, he did say some stuff over in his chat. I'm
just going to read that real quick. Suji, I don't want to litigate
my [__] sex DM's with It's insanely [__]
cringe. But, literally anytime age play [__] has
come up in any of these combos, it is like I had a hot babysitter.
It's cringe how fixated they are, even if it went further. It's
literally just [__] sex thing. Oh, even if it went
further.
Oh, even if it went further, I
I feel like Connor is definitely hinting that it went further.
And so, it's weird that he's saying this right here, okay? Let's
keep watching.
he says, "Okay, well, oh, he then he shared his text message
logs with me." Now, in the text message logs, what I remember
is that he was accusing this person, his wife, of engaging in
step-parent role play, of involving pictures of their of engaging
in lurid ephebophilic, or, depending on your definition, role
play, and how that was repulsive and disgusting, and he hated
her and hated Steven for doing this and destroying his family.
>> Dude, that's that's uh that's pretty
This is pretty bad, man. >> is that he was accusing this
person, his wife, of engaging in step-parent role of involving
pictures of their
of engaging in lurid role play, and how that was repulsive and
disgusting, and he hated her and hated Steven for doing this
and destroying his family.
He says, "Well, she's actually a fan of yours, so why don't you
call her?
>> What does that entail?
I Do I have to describe it? I don't feel like I have to describe
it. I feel like it's described fairly well right there. >> And
talk to her about it and see what kind of evidence or narrative
she gives
So, I do.
And what she says is, "No, that didn't happen. My husband is
exaggerating.
The family pictures had nothing to do with the whole situations
and we engaged in like some babysitter role play or whatever,
but it's not as bad as the husband is making up. You know, she
was the initiator. She was the person who pursued the relationship
and even Steven said, 'Hey, we should cut this off. Like let's
not do this. You're married.
>> So, this is in November of 2025 is what Connor's saying,
okay? >> Your husband is pissed off. You know, let let
let's not do this.
So, to Wick
to Hutch
my Twitter might have gotten hacked, by the way. And so, if my
Twitter profile is texting anything crazy right now, just know
that I've been hacked since
probably 8:00 a.m. this morning.
So, I'm paying
>> a price
for telling the truth, the whole truth and nothing but the truth,
so help me God, as I've seen it, as I remember it. >> I
suspect snarkers are to blame. I suspect snarkers are to blame
right now.
I decide, "Hey, I gave him a shot across the bow. I can't tell
who's telling the truth. I don't know if Steven is being a But,
Steven's a weird guy, so whatever. Or if it's worse.
So, I'm going to put this in I'm going to give Steven a shot
across the bow. I'm going to ask the husband what he wants to
do and I'm going to see if this blows up or blows sideways or
whatever. But, I don't have enough evidence to go forward.
Which brings us to the snarker war. So, so once again, I want
to emphasize
I've heard Hutch saying this should have been done in private.
It was done in private in November of 2025.
I heard Wicks say that this should have been done in private.
It was done in private in November of
>> You know Lauren wanted to get back with
She loves you. She wants the best for you. She thinks that underneath
all the sludge and of your [__] up little life, there's
something redeeming about you. And I agree with her. BUT YOU
ARE SUCH A
THAT IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO be your friend. It's impossible to be
your partner. It is impossible to tell you that you're wrong.
It's impossible for you to take a
So take a L and take a goddamn lap. >> I would just take
a break. I would just take a break from the internet for like
doesn't need to be a long break. I would I if if I was Connor,
I would take a break. I I think it's time to log off for a little
bit. Literally don't even look at the internet for like a week.
Why was this conversation had in public? This is crazy.
Why would this conversation be had on a live stream? >> Counter-Points
should not have done what he did.
going out in public and
basically putting other people's business on blast like that
was very inappropriate. Very
And that's even dis- that that's even disassociating it from
it from like the streamer drama, the the friendship dynamics
there, right? You're you're turning other people's business into
like a weapon, man. Into a
>> Okay. This was private. Steven did not listen to me.
what's got to be frustrating here is you know that these allegations
are out there. You know how crazy the allegations are.
And it's not like
it it's not like he went, "Okay, well, I should back off of this
entirely." For some reason he keeps engaging
with the woman, right? Connor realizes they're still as of like
last week or 2 weeks ago or something.
So, after these allegations already is like damning and gross
as they are, had come out,
Destiny continued to interact with the same person.
To me? He did not consider me. He did not consider Kyla. He did
not consider Dan Saltman. He did not consider Mr. Mouton. He
did not consider any of his future
co-workers. He did not consider America. He did not consider
CNN. He didn't consider a single person when he engaged in this
behavior. And trust me, it gets a little bit worse. So, anyways,
the snarker war. I think that when Hutch and Wick are confused
about what Steven's indiscretions have to do with Steven's snarker
anti-snarker
I think they are either being thoughtless or obtuse.
Pretty clearly, if you listen to any of the snarkers, one of
their primary criticisms of Steven is the way that he conducts
his personal affairs. Whether that's in reference to Sherry,
whether that's in reference to Anna of whether that's in reference
to Melina, whether or not that's in reference to Lauren Southern,
whether or not that's in reference to Pixie or Rose, it's quite
clear that Steven's personal conduct is what he he is he is most
often criticized for by the people who hate him. And not only
that, this conduct is not
It is not.
We found out about Melina and Lauren Southern and Rose because
Steven sent his not only homemade to Rose. Dude, I I should say
just in terms of it not being private, there's another thing
here where
if if Destiny had a need for this, right? Like I have a different
thing where I'm like, if I don't hear about it, I don't care.
Like just keep it private, right? If it was just malicious people
leaking this stuff, I would maybe understand, but it sounds like
Destiny intentionally engages in this sort of stuff with people
who are not stable.
Right? Like he found somebody who is not stable to engage in
this stuff with.
and that risks it becoming public.
And realistically, I
That risks it becoming public, okay? Which is harmful in and
of itself.
>> So, on Saturday, might have even been Friday night,
I get a message from Brittany.
Brittany contacts me. She says, "Oh, it's crazy. I'm so sorry
that you and Steven are breaking up."
Steven and I are still talking. So, I want you to understand
this. Steven text messaged
a woman, did age play scenarios with
got a shot across the bow, "Hey, this is up in
and he kept doing it.
Not only that,
this is going to be a tough one. Give me a second.
but her and her husband are broken up,
but Steven thought it was prudent
to receive
of the husband
and this wife.
I want you to understand that. >> Wait, what?
>> Britt vacillates between endless adoration and love
for Steven. She truly loves him on a fundamental
>> I guess that's why everybody has been saying over and
over again that both of them were involved in this thing, which
is incredibly disturbing. That didn't come after the thing with
the kids, right? There's no way that There's no >> She
thinks he's the best thing since sliced bread.
When Steven is not around and is not communicating with her,
she gets
because she's mentally unwell.
Her husband has blamed Steven for the implosion
of his family.
Steven received a video of these two mentally unstable, homicidal,
and
military veterans having for his personal enjoyment.
That is something that I was told on Saturday, and by the way,
that was confirmed by both parties.
That was confirmed by Brett, and that was confirmed by Devil.
So, you can imagine
This is nuts.
I actually think if this guy sincerely thought there was like
the kids were involved in some way, and then they continued in
this the husband, I mean. I don't know that you should have your
Man, I I'm just going to keep watching. I'm taking in the information.
rage, and taking in information. that my
who is $800,000
because he was imprudently
is still being imprudently
in a way that could get him killed.
And in a way that could result in a
I am obviously angry about this fact.
It gets worse.
The snarkers have not corrupted my mind. They have not mind me.
They have not manipulated me into my position. If you take a
look at my previous content
I have been quite clearly
critical about Steven's misadventures.
And when I thought he was doing better I was praising him, and
when I thought he was up, I was criticizing him. So, to
So, you can call him a PDF now, right? Um, I mean, you guys can
call it whatever you want. I I'm just taking in the information,
man. that Jay Stock, Queenan, or Doobie talked to me for 2 weeks
and that somehow changed everything it did not. You were just
not paying attention to what I was saying previously. The snarkers
have given me one thing
and one thing alone.
I have verified that this is Britt through information
that I have saved.
She wrote in to Mr. Girl's call-in show via email to discuss
her relationship with Steven.
Mr. Girl's involved? >> This is confirmed.
I cannot be sued for this
because I have the evidence that backs up the truth of this scenario.
Let's listen. >> This year I was involved in an online
affair with a guy for almost a year. My husband wouldn't engage
with any of the weird trauma-induced kink stuff that I was curious
about, and so I was compelled to impulsively and regrettably
regrettably engage with this guy online in some pretty intense
and taboo age play scenarios, including fantasizing about being
step-parents to each other's
And obviously it went way too far.
that totally undercuts under it totally undermines the wife saying,
"No, no, no, this didn't happen. No, no, no, my husband's just
overexaggerating."
Now, I've looked at this link Somebody sent me this link cuz
they're ahead on the stream.
This is in January, so this is after she sent this
the November 2025 leaks.
She sent this after.
So, she was already confronted and she'd already told Connor
that her husband wasn't that her husband was making this up.
And then she sent this email to Max.
>> fantasizing about being stuff that I was curious about,
and so I was compelled to impulsively and regrettably regrettably
engage with this guy online in some pretty intense and taboo
age play scenarios, including fantasizing about being step-parents
to each other's kids. And obviously it went way too far, but
felt really intensely good in the moment. But afterward I felt
sick and cried all night because it obviously felt really bad,
too. How do you know if the other person also feels the same
way or if they would actually do it? My understanding is the
best predictors
are drug use and low empathy. Uh and even worse, what if you
felt like you love them so much that you wouldn't care if they
did and you get off on what you potentially be willing to allow
them to get away with? What if the idea is kind of enticing to
you in a way even if you deny it or try to lie to yourself about
it? Even if you never act out on something like that yourself,
lucky for me, it's over now.
If you're saying that you doubt
your willingness to hold boundaries in real life, then that is
danger. Yes. >> Dude, back in November,
I had two conflicting stories.
Devil told me that this was the scenario, that there was step-parent
role-play involving
said, "No.
It was babysitter [__] Devil's
>> I got the message.
Connor's getting his phone blown up. Oh, >> is an email
confirmed to be Brit
sent to Mr. Girl.
So, if I had to prescribe for Steven, trying not to hate him,
then I would say, this is my unsolicited
Destiny should balance his spicy public takes to be spicy enough
to get attention, but not so violent and criticizable that people
want to murder him. He cannot,
in good faith and good conscience, blame the doxing s- and harassment
and attempted homicides solely on the stochastic permission structure
created by his snarkers.
He cannot do that while he is a woman who is presently married,
who is hanging out in a traditional Catholic group chat that
was plotting or at least joking
and stochastically trying to work each other up to his homicide.
That is a [__] lie.
Destiny should evidence his claims that Snark is responsible
for his swatting, doxxing, and digital harassment beyond
Destiny should focus on political commentary and community development
in order to get another college event / canvassing operation
going for both of the midterms in 2028.
If he wasn't a
Instead,
he's on the [__] internet using a champion to defend
his honor against shits criticizing his personal life. Meanwhile,
he engages in even dumber reprehensible
actions.
God damn. And his [__] cult of say
that I'm pocket watching because I'm worried about him losing
$800,000 in legal expenses. >> They actually say you're
watching mostly Connor, but >> They say that I'm watching
because I'm criticizing him for engaging in stepdad
roleplay with a random insane
woman on the internet while he's being sued for his misconduct.
So, no offense
to the people in my chat who are likely spurging the [__]
out who I cannot presently see. But, if you say pocket watching
or if you say
you're a piece of [__] and you would let Steven kill
himself
if it amused you for 2 seconds on the
>> Speaking of that, my stance is that it is not neutral
or positive to engage in a theebaphilic or roleplay.
I think it's bad.
If you think it's neutral or good
and you are a current member of my community, I ask one of two
things from You either keep that opinion >> Any clarification
on the couple of step parents situation? It sounds like Destiny
was engaging as a step parent in some fantasy role play that
made this woman uncomfortable. Now, why would you call it step
parent role play that went way too far and made you feel disgusted
if being a step parent didn't matter if it was just the two of
you operating,
>> into yourself, or you leave my community.
And if, let's say that all of my oilers, all of my chippers,
all of my community support come from people who think this is
not a big deal, and who think that it is perfectly sane and rational
for Steven to be
in homicidal people while currently being sued for misconduct,
I don't want your money.
I would rather destroy my stream
>> is like one of his top guys.
No way. The scenarios didn't involve their children. It involved
scenarios of them being step parents. Or
>> gaming career, >> and I would rather go back to
working construction administration as a nobody
who participates in the space as a than continue to rely on your
viewership or financial support. >> It's actually over?
It's not over at all. It's not over at all. This will literally
not affect Destiny's like primary support but from his audience
one iota. Just so you know, if you think if you think anything
said here would affect any supporter of his
you are wrong. You are coping.
This doesn't affect him with his viewers one tiny iota.
Not even a little bit. There is not a single Destiny viewer who
has any problem with any of the things
And if they did, they would no longer be
>> How about you take this L? We've been secretly dating
for 3 months. He was lying when he said that I asked out Lauren
and got rejected,
he was lying. When he has implied that what has motivated me
is jealousy out of his relationship with Lauren Southern, he
is lying to you. >> Connor, if you want to L, me and Lauren
have been dating for like 3 months and we both agreed not to
tell you because you asked her >> So, I'm going to pause
it right there because he just lied. He just lied, guys. He's
not dating Lauren. He's not dating Lauren. He just lied.
He just lied that he's still dating Lauren to try and get one
over on Connor in this conversation.
He literally immediately after this, he goes into DGG
and admits, he says,
"Guys, I'm sorry. I misrepresented.
Me and Lauren broke up 2 weeks ago. She's been so over by every
guy in her
No joke, that's what he goes to DGG and says immediately after.
You know, he's trembling, freaking the [__] out because
he obviously actually does kind of care about Lauren a little
bit deep down and he just literally he throws it away in this
moment to try and get the win for his ego. >> Rather than
engaging in a healthy relationship with a woman he loves, he
would rather go do step parent age play with random women on
Discord and
He is a socially ins human being who has destroyed his personal
and professional life because he is so
And I am not going to be a part of it. I'm not going to be silent
about it.
It is not a crazy stance. Might be a crazy stance in some online
communities, but it is not a crazy stance to say that in a role
play is crazy. It is not a crazy stance to say that engaging
in this kind of reckless behavior while under civil lawsuit for
other reckless behavior is patently
And I will not be gaslit by moral cowards into other perspectives.
Specifically, thank you Hutch. Thank you Wick. Why is this all
in the open? I don't know. Why the [__] do I know
about
>> Why is this happening IN PUBLIC? I KNOW. I KNOW. ISN'T
THAT A GREAT QUESTION TO ASK? BUT YOU'RE ASKING THE WRONG PERSON.
>> is his private life, and his private life is private,
why do I know about it? Is it because he recklessly engaged with
mentally ill people who contacted me and told me about it? Is
that why?
>> The husband's about to call in. Got husband in. Husband
coming in hot. >> I've asserted that Britt engaged, based
off of your information by the way, um that Steven and Britt
engaged in age role play, step parent role play, involving your
back in the day, like November in last
All right. In terms of the Mr. Girl >> It's I mean that's
pretty much there. Everybody who, you know, everybody's saying
that, uh, it's pretty much But in terms of the Mr. Girl stuff,
if I can talk about anything, I guess, uh, from what I understand,
she played up a lot of that because she was like watching Mr.
Girl at the time and blah blah blah. And when she wrote in, she
elaborated a bit, is my understanding of what she's telling me.
I don't have any direct knowledge of that stuff, so. >> So,
uh, what's the What What is your understanding? Because obviously
we had a conversation in November. And I think that you told
me something almost identical to what Britt wrote into Mr. Girl.
So, where was that coming from? >> She never told me like
the parts about him uh or her being turned on by him actually
doing it IRL. Like none of that was ever mentioned. It was always
just, "Hey, this is a thing that happened one time. He didn't
really want to do it, but I kind of wanted to do it, and we both
felt bad about it and didn't do it anymore." That was the story
she gave me. But never denied it happening, of course. But that
was like it wasn't this ongoing thing supposedly, from what I
know. But like I said, I'm just going
I never saw the logs between them. It was mostly like on >> um
I'm going to I'm going to disconnect this call and I'm going
to point something out to chat. Okay. So,
wrote to me.
Immediately Oh, he he's going to lean into the fact that the
husband just said that it happened. I am.
>> I can call in. >> But I'm going to downplay
everything. I'm actually even going to go ahead and omit a detail.
So, I can save Devil a little bit of heartache. Here you go.
>> Yeah, I I mean I already said this that the guy is going
to like this is a serious situation where where the health and
safety of his kids is at question. So, obviously he'd have to
downplay it and the guy saying this is
Yeah, I okay. Well,
>> So, no offense.
You dumb [__]
But everybody's lying. So, once again, this So, don't worry.
You want the evidence?
I got you. I got you. Devil, if you want to call back in, go
ahead. But the only thing that I want to hear from you is what
I heard from you in November.
So, if you want me to call you, I'll call you.
But I'm not I'm not doing this mm self-sweeping [__]
So, if you need to self-sweep because this is serious, that's
fine. But I'm not helping you self-sweep. Hello?
>> I can hear you. Now, Devil, I'm going to say this and
I'm going to say this exactly once. You and I spoke in November.
You made some extreme like allegations against
I wasn't able to make heads or tails. That Mr. Girl email sounds
identical to the messages or excuse me, to the allegations that
you were making in >> I have >> on my screen right
now. I can, but I'm going to downplay everything. So, if you
want to talk to me about what really happened, then I'll be happy
to talk to you. If you want to me about what's going on, I will
literally just take all the screenshots of all the messages that
I have between you, me, and Brett. I'll remove you guys' personal
identifying information and I'll release it on Twitter because
that's what you wanted to do in November.
>> By downplaying, I did not mean that I was going to lie.
Simply mean that I'm not going to go into all the details, specific
details that can get me and my family personally [__]
up. Because you know, that seems like a sensible thing to do.
Now, I will talk to you and I will tell you and like I said,
leave the logs if you want. >> I mean, he's quite literally
he's quite literally saying that this happened right now. >> But
But, I like I had no knowledge of some of the things she said
in that email. And from what I understand what she told me >> Then
why did you tell me the exact same thing that was in the email
in November?
>> Oh, brother. This guy's not ready. >> What did
I tell you in the email? Like I don't even I have screenshots.
I can go pull it up. I don't know exactly >> I'll tell
you exactly what you told me because I still got screenshots.
So, you told me in November that Brit and
were role-playing as parents
in reference to their own
You also told me that they role-played as your >> Okay,
but specifically like I said, in terms of downplaying I mean,
I'm going to give you because I'm not going to try to like drop
>> Oh, dude. Oh. >> How did that not happen? >> That
is what I was told. I have no direct evidence of that. I do not
know >> So, you don't have the video or screenshots that
Britney said that that happened to you. >> I mean, Britney
told you the same thing, didn't she? >> She did. But, look
Well, actually hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold up. Britney downplayed
it and she said that they did babysitting fantasies. >> Well,
that was >> So, you were Hold on. Hold on. To be clear,
what happened is you told me exactly what was in the mister girl
Then Brit told me that they just did babysitting fantasies. I
wasn't able to make heads or tails of it. The only reason why
I was going public with this is because Brit wrote mister girl
telling me what you told me. >> Yeah, okay. Yeah, I I I
didn't know Well, I don't know everything she told you either.
I've never seen y'all's logs or y'all's conversations, but I
just know what she told me and she told me that that happened
once and never happened again. And if downplaying is just telling
the truth about what she told me, I mean, I don't think I said
that they were doing it constantly either and I shouldn't have
even gotten into all that personally, but I was, you know, crashing
out at the time. It is what it >> But, why were you crashing
out at the >> By the way, I called her a schizo earlier.
She's not a schizo. She is She does have BPD, but she's not a
schizo. I can clear that up. >> That's funny. Why were
you crashing out? >> She's still an adult. She can still
do what she wants, you know. It's It is what it is. We're kind
of trying to move past it. We're kind of trying to move Oh, because
she had an affair with Destiny. I mean, among all the others,
you know, pretty obvious. >> Okay, did Destiny know you
were married?
>> I don't even know if that's public knowledge or any
of that is.
Is it? I don't know. I mean, it I don't know.
You know that was in contention. >> Oh, we're caught up.
We're caught up. >> It's not in contention. The reason
Okay, let me tell you what I'm trying to do,
What I'm trying to point The Let me tell you the the picture
that I'm trying to
The picture that I'm trying to paint is you came to me in November
and you said >> Listen, look. >> that they role-played
as step-parents
that Steven received pictures of your
that were not in a context, but she he still knew what they looked
like. They role-played stepmom, stepdad fantasies in which the
were being
And then, they also role-played as the themselves engaging in
an tryst, and that was so disturbing to you that you wished you
could destroy the online personal and professional reputation
of Destiny.
That's what you told me in November. So, is that accurate or
not? >> At the time, I definitely did want to destroy the
online personal reputation of Destiny. This is true. Yeah.
>> Okay. And was my description of what you told me in
November accurate or no?
>> Uh I don't remember if I said exactly like that. Like
I said, I'd have to pull it up. Uh but, it I mean, I was pissed.
I pretty much just told you generally what she told me. Um
I I Who knows? I I Like I said, I really need to go back and
look at it. It's been so long. I'm trying to move past it, you
know? Trying to get my own going on, you know, get my own thing
together,
in terms of I mean I mean, like I said, you got the logs. I don't
even know why you need me to be honest. So, I don't really personally
want to >> So, so the thing that you wanted to The thing
that you wanted to clarify is that you are uh you were not in
a telecr- a Telegram group that was planning Destiny's hot
>> I was not in a Telegram group. There was a conversation
that happened, and I essentially said like like what you're doing
is insane. You got to chill. Blah, blah Like, you know, you're
going to get to way too many eyes on us. Shit's going to hit
the fan at some point, >> you know. Uh what what else do
you want to clarify?
I don't know, man. I just want everybody to know that like
are me and Destiny best friends? No, but I don't hate him now.
Like, he's a [__] adult, she is, too. He can dig
his own grave, do what he wants to, and she can, too. It's none
of my business anymore. I just wanted to kind of move past this.
I know there's a lot of other people who have ruined this, blah
blah blah. I've heard all the different things, but I mean, this
is Destiny. Like, what what are you going to do? BPD girl wants
to reach out to him, and they're going to reach out to him. You
can't get him
>> wife. Dude, I uh I just
>> I'm sick, man. >> At this point, it's kind of
ruining my life even more. Like, I was It's been 6 months now,
and I'm like, kind of want to just move past this. >> I
understand that, but we're we're in it, man. You involved me
in November, and Britt involved me last week. So, we're in it,
whether you like it or not. So, did uh did Britt I I legitimately
feel like ill watching this. Britt, did Britt convince you to
shoot homemade and then send it to Steven? >> No, no, no,
no, no, no, no. I'm not going to I'm not going to I'm not going
to do that. I'm not going to do that, I'm not doing that, Connor.
>> All right. >> What What else do you want to clarify?
>> Like I said, I don't want to get into like all the different
It's It's [__] complicated, you know what I mean?
And like, as far as I'm concerned, I haven't
I guess it's all I really need to clarify. I don't know, man.
It just sucks, and I wish people would just back off and just
kind of let us live our lives at this point. >> Okay. Well,
Devin,
I'll I'll tell you. I'll tell you right I would have loved
for all of us to have moved on and lived our lives. But,
what happened was Steven was making claims that riled the
Connor, why were you mad at Destiny still messaging Britt if
she was single?
>> and whatever. They are responsible for the doxing, swatting,
and harassment and threats to his life. >> Oh, these people
are ill. These people ill, man.
Like these are the people who've been defending him. I knew I
said that they it wouldn't make a dent, but it's just gross to
watch in real time. >> I got you in November saying that
you wish you could destroy Steven's life and alleging some pretty
extreme things about what he did with your wife. And then I got
Britt writing into Mr. Girl identifying nearly identically
exactly what you described to me. Then I have Britt contacting
me on Friday stating that not only did that Telegram [__]
exist, but then on top of that that she is currently in communications
with Destiny right now. So for me, I know this sucks. I know
that I'm I do not I do not dislike you at all. But what's happening
is because you're scared, you're walking back [__]
that you told me previously. And I'm not I'm really just going
to release the >> I mean that's that's that's fine, man.
I don't you know, I'm I'll I'll message you later about some
[__] but look like at the end of the day, these are
two adults. It happened one time according to them. That's what
she told me back then, too. I got I got logs with her, too, talking
about it. And like she's supposedly She I mean she's in therapy
now, man. Like she's she's trying to get her [__]
together, and if she wants to message Destiny from time to time,
it's not that deep, honestly, I feel like. But yeah, is it [__]
up? Yeah, it's [__] up. Would I do it? No. Is it
D-gen? I think so. But if nothing ever happened that was technically
illegal, it's [__] up as it is, and I'm trying to
maintain peace and harmony in my life as much as I can. And yeah,
sure, I don't really give a [__] if you want to kill
Destiny. I'm sure there's like 20 communities out there that
want to kill Destiny. Wow, you know, like what >> This
guy's ex-wife. Ex-wife. >> tells his new he's Destiny.
He's Destiny. What are you going to do? Yeah, I just thought
that this is [__] up. But yeah, at the end of the
day, I have no beef for Destiny. I'm sure a lot of people have
valid reasons, too, and I probably do, too, but I'm willing to
live and let go and move on. >> He's using stalker terms.
>> my life and I hope that whatever snarkers he's gay fake
internet [__] he's involved with, you know, I hope
that works out for him. >> Okay. Well, then anything else
you want to clarify before I let you go.
>> Uh that nothing much. It was a interesting being, you
know, uh
bit infamous for a minute. I hope it passes over. Wouldn't recommend,
but thanks for letting me call in and clarify a few things. >> All
right. Goodnight, bud.
>> All right. Stay safe. Don't die. >> You too.